Okay, so let's continue with uh the
discussion on using the transformer
models and why they quickly became our
main tool for learning from large data
sets. So we introduced transformers and
we discussed that self attention
basically enables this representation of
the the context and then we discussed
vision transformers that uses the the
encoder part of the transformer to do
image classification for us. they can
continue improving and we didn't see a
plateau like what we saw for CNN's and
the question that we are asking is
basically is there a limit for the
improvement and how far we can go
because of it getting to its limit. So
the main discovery that uh was made uh
or observed
uh back in 2020 was the performance
improvement from scaling of resources,
model size, the data is not only
possible but also we can predict them
like how much we will improve which
basically gave justification
for going for larger models, larger data
sets. that's and larger compute cuz we
know that we are going to get better
performance. So what I'm talking about
here is there is a mathematical law uh
in a power law form that basically says
given three different scaling dimension
namely model size the data set size in
terms of the number of tokens in that
data set and the compute budget in terms
of the number of floating point
operation and the discovery is basically
for each one of these dimension we have
a power law performance improvement and
it tells us how much improvement we can
expect with increasing of each one of
these dimension. This gave us a
predictive planning. So if we do uh if
we invest this much we will get this
much improvement which help us to
allocate resources and uh allocate uh
investments also and that explained
progress of for example GPT models even
after the discovery of th those um laws.
um the models that came after that
confirm those laws and that gives us an
empirical sense of scaling. So let's go
back to the equation. For example, the
loss that we observe uh based on some
dimension
is an addition of a constant
a reducible loss something that we
cannot do anything about. It's just like
the entropy or the uncertainty in the
data just the data is like that and then
a power law term
which is about the reducible loss
and the gap between the model and the
optimal performance. So the optimal is
basically this something that is the
best performance.
So the idea here is
we can
determine
this constants
empirically.
For example, for language models, the
exponents
across each dimension
is approximated like this. So for
example here we see the slowest
improvement for uh investing in compute
and the most improvement for investing
in the data set size.
So what I mean is something like this
basically if you increase the parameter
the loss will decrease. So for example
it's something like this. If you
increase the performance, the SL loss
will decrease with this rate that is
determined this way. Uh getting closer
and closer to this reducible loss and
same for the number of tokens and the
number of flops. And this remarkable
finding really holds for different
modalities. Those constants may change
but the power law form so far stands the
test of time. So the the maybe the first
paper that started the the whole
conversation is this paper by Kaplan and
uh colleagues back in 2020. But um
something that I want to point out other
than uh this uh general laws is there is
a surprising result that larger models
are also more sample efficient. meaning
that larger models can squeeze more
information from the examples that they
are seeing which is somehow
counterintuitive. So all of these
results uh led to um the seminal paper
of GPT3 uh which was a massive bet on
the scaling. GPT3 has 175 billion
parameters. And with all of these
resources and the cost of uh several
million dollars uh for the for its
training, it confirmed that scaling law
and matched the prediction. Other models
that came after GPT3 like for example
models by Deep Mind also confirm this
observation. But things even get better
that oh maybe we are undertraining this
model we can do even better. So the
scaling can be even more optimal and
that's where the chinchilla models came
in with this new notion of compute
optimal language models. But the main
maybe the main result of um this paper
was connecting these different
dimensions. For example, parameters and
tokens should scale equally and not for
example in one side. And another
practical rule that it says that
approximately 20 token per parameter is
a good rule of thumb. So if we have more
parameters, we can feed more data and
learn more.
So they basically came up with this
parametric form that uh if you remember
similar to the lecture on efficient net
it help us to
design
more optimal architectures
and language models
and update those uh power law uh
coefficients.
So the take-home message somehow changed
slightly uh from the as big as possible
to compute optimal size with much more
data and chinchilla for example they
showed that they can achieve similar
performance with much less number of
parameters but with more tokens. I mean
still we are doing power law but in a
more efficient way and they showed that
uh in their comparison of chinchilla
with the gopher which is a very large
model and chinchilla with much less
number of parameter but more tokens in
the training performs much better in a
lot of benchmarks. So there are a lot of
other models that came after chinchilla
but they uh started using this
principles that well we can give more
tokens to less to smaller models and
gained similar performances. So that's
why you will see the ratio of token to
parameter
now much higher than those old models.
So then you can revisit these models for
example GPT3
and retrain them with more tokens and
you will get better performance and
that's where you get a better and
optimal GPT3 which then requires much
more number of tokens and then you can
just extrapolate to future models. There
are of course some caveats to this
story. For example, well, hey, what if
the this tokens are just repeated tokens
and things like that, which basically
means the data is not new, which I'm
going to skip. But of course, these are
those caveats. But the the main thing
here is if we can achieve the same
performance with smaller model we should
do it because then those models are
cheaper doing inference and then they
will be picked up more which is the name
of the game for any products. So if um
just to give you a sketch of uh y power
law uh we have to drill down into this
type of loss that we use in the auto
reggressive mainly auto reggressive
tasks and that's the cross entropy. So
there are resources like papers and even
YouTube videos that I will uh reference
on why that's the case.